Чи є в Антарктиді слони?
Це питання може здаватись гумористичним,
а насправді є
Коли мене запитують:
«От яка вона, ота Антарктида?»
Чесно кажучи, це завжди викликає
спершу посмішку,
бо, в першу чергу, вона велика!
В історії українців в Антарктиді були
не лише героїчні та світлі сторінки
І отут нам приходять на допомогу пінгвіни
Так, ті самі легендарні пінгвіни,
яких ви однозначно бачили
Доброго дня, дорогі школярі!
Цього року багато хто з вас писав твори на конкурс «Запроси полярника до себе»
27 шкіл було визнано переможцями
І мої колеги, українські дослідники Антарктиди, мали прийти в ці школи,
поспілкуватися з вами вживу, розповісти про те,
що, як і для чого вивчають на українській антарктичній станції «Академік Вернадський»
І порівняти реальність із тим, що
ви описували у своїх творах
Частину шкіл ми встигли відвідати, але, на жаль, більшу частину через карантин не змогли
Ми обов'язково прийдемо у всі ці школи,
коли би не почався новий навчальний рік
Однак поки карантин, ми вирішили не чекати,
а замість цього записати для вас цикл
маленьких таких онлайн-уроків
Дивіться нас YouTube-каналі
Міністерства освіти і науки України,
Facebook-сторінках МОН
і Національного антарктичного наукового центру